تتجدد الغارات الاسرائيليه في ساعات الليل
على مناطق متفرقه من مدينه رفح لليوم
الثالث على التوالي قصف جديد يستهدف شقه
سكنيه في منطقه غرب مدينه رفح اوقع عدد من
الشهداء والجرحى من بين الجرحى كما
تشاهدون
اطفال وايضا تم نقل جث عدد من الشهداء
بالاضافه الى
اصابات الى المستشفى الكويتي
القريب من هذا المنزل المستهدف
نشاهد حجم الدمار الذي
احدثه
القصف الاسرائيلي لهذا المنزل الماهول
بالسكان وهنا جثمان
يبدو
شهيد
هذه يحاول شبان انتشال
جثمانه الشهيد
يبد القصف الحق دمارا في المنطقه واشتعال
للنيران
النيران لازالت مشتعله في المنزل المستهدف
حتى ان جثمان هذا الشهيد ملقى في الشارع
من شده القصف الذي تعرض له المنزل
المستهدف الشبان
يحاولون انتشاله بوسائل بدائيه عب لوح من
الخشب نساء واطفال من ضمن الاصابات وضحايا
هذا
القصف
الاسرائيلي الذي استهدف
الامنين في
ساعات متاخره من الليل
هنا
تشاهدون
القص لا اله الا الله حاله من لل والعر
اصابت جيران المنزل المستهدف وبطبيعه
الحال هنا في مدينه رفح جميع المنازل تؤوي
عائلات نزحت من غزه والمنطقه الشماليه
وهذه هي المنطقه الامنه التي يدعي جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي انها امنه هنا يقع
المنزل المستهدف لازال رجال الدفاع المدني
يحاولون اطفاء الحريق الذي اندلع
نتيجه القصف الاسرائيلي النيران لازالت
مشتعله
داخل
هذا
المنزل
المستهدف اضرار ماديه كبيره في المنازل
المجاوره وايضا
في الممتلكات العامه والسيارات في
الشارع يساعد الشبان وجيران هذا المنزل
الدفاع المدني في اخماد النيران التي
اندلعت في المنزل المستهدف نتيجه قصفه
بصاروخ واحد على الاقل وسمعنا دوي انفجار
كبير ناجم عن هذه الغاره الاسرائيليه التي
استهدفت استهدفت هذا المنزل حتى ان جثمانه
سيده تطايره من داخل منزل الى الشارع كما
شاهدنا قبل
قليل بامكانيات بسيطه
ومحدوده يحاولون انقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه
ويحاولون ايضا اخماد
النيران
المشتعله داخل المنزل
المستهدف كما تشاهدون هذه اثار القصف
والغاره الاسرائيليه التي استهدفت هذا
المنزل واوقعت عددا من الضحايا والمصابين
سواء من سكان المنزل او سكان او من جيران
المنزل بطبيعه
الحال الى جانب الاضرار الماديه الكبيره
التي خلفها القصف الاسرائيلي في هذه
الساعه المتاخره من الليل في منطقه مزدحمه
نتحدث عن مدينه رفح التي تؤوي اكثر من
مليون و300 الف نازح اي غاره واي قصف
اسرائيلي في ساعات الليل المتاخر بالتاكيد
توقع العديد من الضحايا والمصابين الى
جانب الاضرار الماديه مع تصاعد وتيره
القصف والغارات الاسرائيليه خلال الساعات
والايام الماضيه على مدينه رفح مؤمن شرافي
الجزيره رفح